I'm recording one second of every day
of my life for the rest of my life,
chronologically compiling
these one-second
tinyslices of my life into
one single continuous video
until, you know,
I can't record them anymore.
The purpose of this project is, one:
I hate not remembering things
that I've done in the past.
There's all these things
that I've done with my life
that I have no recollection of
unlesssomeone brings it up,
and sometimes I think,
"Oh yeah, that's something that I did."
It'salso kind of a personal protest,
against the culture we have now
where peoplejust are at concerts
with their cell phones out
recording the whole concert.
I admittedlyused to be that
guy a little bit, back in the day,
and I've decided that the best way
for meto still capture and keep
a visual memory of my life
and not be that person,
is to justrecord that one second
that will allow me to
trigger that memory of,
"Yeah, that concertwas amazing.
I really loved that concert."